she was a beautiful beautiful she
continues to be a beautiful spirit
rick springfield gets choked up
remembering his pal the late olivia
newton john
my eyes
are not the first
to cry
grab your tissues as rick opens up on
the today show in australia about the
close bond he shared with his fellow
aussie native we can see how it's
affecting you we can see
that you're being very vulnerable with
us and we so appreciate that but i just
want to say how how are you feeling are
you okay
yeah yeah
um like i
i got a
a message from her camp that that things
weren't going well a couple of days ago
um so i you know it wasn't a giant shock
but it is always a shock when they
finally go
olivia died monday at her ranch in
southern california surrounded by her
loved ones after a long battle against
breast cancer she was 73. rick recalls
spending a lot of quality time together
over the years especially when they were
both just two aussie natives trying to
make it big in the states trying to
break in america we're both doing the
same thing around the same time
so we saw a lot quite a bit of each
other then
and um
you know it was just i mean
it was a great camaraderie amongst
aussies back then over here it was just
uh like hugging home you know
being together
after olivia died rick shared a touching
tribute on instagram quote sweet olivia
has gone home she was a beautiful soul
and i know of no one who didn't love her
you know
she was an amazing human being and
it's just so easy to love and i don't
know anybody who
ever had a negative word to say about
her but rick isn't the only star
commemorating olivia's legacy
well her legacy is of course her talent
her her authenticity
her ability to share care and make a
difference in the world
especially in the world of cancer which
is something that she um
she learnt to have to live with
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you think her legacy will be
first of all the music course
but i think um anyone that knew her
will always remember her as being one of
the nicest
kindest
giving and caring person they've ever
met i'm gonna miss her a lot olivia was
pop culture royalty as a grammy winner
and of course most famously for her role
as sandy in greece
sandy
tell me about it
[Music]
she is this perennial favorite and she
will forever be sandy and you know
summer nights and um hopelessly devoted
and all those incredible songs are
etched into our public consciousness
[Music]
i think in the end
she got everything that she wanted in
her life she never talked about herself
she never bragged on her accomplishments
and rick echoed that same sentiment that
olivia never let fame go to her head it
didn't really
change her you know she did she never
had a
giant ego more she was thankful i guess
is probably
the best thing
way to explain it um never took anything
anything for granted